some people wake up in the morning and
they try to figure out how they're gonna
get out of bed we wake up in the morning
and hike up a mountain carrying water
and camera gear what'd you do today our
morning was like the beginning of the
poacher video I'm going to leave it at
that I don't know look at the script I
don't even have a memorize sounds like
they got some vicious animals there
don't hurt them oh wait we might be next
we might be next we mean we might be the
next vicious animals goodbye that here
you go we're gonna do the first shot
first shot first shot I camera rolling
hi actors acting got eyes on the outpost
looks like they're keeping some dishes
animals in there though better watch out
or you might be next
cool what uh that's first steak who's
always always the Google a ski strip
dude well just cuz I need to read the
words on it or maybe propping up stick
huh just just prop it up or something
with this rock I don't know how to do it
yeah that's perfect right there you
can't see that right hey right right
classic guitar ski Krone Sun with the
snipes I'm supposed to under with my
eyes with my script isn't here
cam has a toucan sam on his shirt what's
his report yeah sure why not
oh that actually do it for the sound
design there what would you do is hear
like a distant X that would strengthen
since the door
sup guys you may have seen us rocking
this tripod in the behind the scenes of
the poacher the Sackler carbon fiber HD
tripod High Definition three legs stable
camera holdin yes super nice super light
operated by one person goes anywhere
including the top of a mountain
alright let's get the shot action nice
cut I hope someone catches the
three-finger dad just video I really
hope so cuz I'm putting a lot of effort
into it it was your other hands my left
hand you were standing like this and you
put it on there and then he looked like
this and it's also Jan's missing his
left finger like that's perfect as I can
walk around like this all day
okay no just like hold your hand or scam
like this twist them radio on your
handlebar action nice alright yeah yeah
yeah
so I poked myself but because I was
trying to do this to offer day alright
ready one more time providing something
out of the cages now each time I breathe
like that I get dizzy and I can't act
I'm just like pass out and like stop
acting this is what happened when we
were doing fart attack when I was doing
like this manga fart going like one part
I almost like passed out after screaming
it was like 90 degrees out I just like
sitting there going for like a half hour
face it wide shot there's like 20 goats
around me that's what goes somewhere
we're gonna do the go tons for this
video what's authentic you want anymore
my friend really wanted to go up there
so as an experienced cat we let him
right here I'm worried about walking up
the cliff you do I was like sue Oh like
I'm using it they see me saying hey do
you want to say this is for my pinky
Jake could you grab me no compassion
right here
here's a protip for you guys if you need
to get shot we're like you're just
looking at nothing like there's no
people in the shot it's like I do like
really like impending doom kind of like
push in or like an artsy pan of like
trees or some like that shoot at 48
frames per second band you'll take out
all the little bumps of your hand
because it's in slow motion technically
just move a little bit faster and then
apply little stabilization on top of
that you have a really smooth shot if
you want an example the shot of the
ferry moving across the screen at the
end of a link shadow is shot 48 prints a
second it looks super smooth so yeah he
goes pro tips yeah it's more to come
sans for tip I just got them both that
Alex pro tip who's pro tip is to jam it
on a pro tip these are all great how
great they're really great cuz all you
got to do to get great shots around here
is spin in a random direction and then
start recording it's perfect I just
literally walked around the entire Hill
getting ominous shots of goat sounds
coming up the hills and I literally just
ended up doing a circle circle around
the entire Vista and everything looks
cool what do you know and that's why
it's worth it to hike up a hill for an
hour to shoot at a cool location like
this you don't have to do any VCG felon
not that much alright I'm nothing but in
order to know how high these goats will
fly through the air in an explosion
we have Niko here performing our very
own goat simulator take it away since
all objects are of mass regardless of
how much mass they have fall at equal
speeds I'm going to take these three
rocks which will equate three goats and
toss them in the air with the
approximate equivalent energy of a motor
verse alright and I'll record this ready
yep rolling alright here comes a
murderer and boom
awesome and now we have an accurate
simulation of goats because here's the
thing that mortar blasts is way stronger
than Niko's hand so you count for the
fact that they would fly super high once
again big things to drone fly calm for
the drone guess the best yeah I got
these fat shot goggles courtesy of fat
shark thanks bad shark this is like the
oculus rift but with the drone
got a deal with his tail on my tail that
doesn't know that sounds super funny I
was just saying like can I sell
something how about uh got it okay
she'll be great one-take wonder is that
looked awesome that was great
you're a big spot you'd be like this
okay catch it
action oh that's the weakest thing I've
ever seen no time to prepare three two
one action huh
three two one action
wow that was like incredibly awkward he
just says I can do it again but cooler
yeah Wow let's give up oh you mean the
teeth no what do you call us we're
almost come on Nico use your eyes go oh
my god you're done ah oh my god oh yeah
laughing literally hitting you on the
daily cycle promoter n creeping fish oh
that's it
lunch is over after that shall we shoot
your Tiger reaction shot with the
biggest scream you've ever screamed yes
this is your last screen of the day
let me get count yeah go up with a
scream
we got it good like a teakettle
when you need movie dirt you just go up
to a burnt tree oh man I'm glittering
what you see the glitter I think soon I
was gonna do like swoops up yeah like
that I'm ready these are the mortar
blasts I mean do I just have a black
face right now that's right one for my
crutch got some on that shirt no no I
just got the shirt okay what does a
nightmare DS Damon well I think we're
really perfecting this whole like you
know four-man crew thing it's working
pretty well we're also getting really
good at lighting with the Sun the entire
time just washed my face off heaven the
last fish for the day getting right off
into that sunset probably treat myself
to a burger and fries final thoughts
we're uh actually it's been a long long
time since we just made a video where
we're actually in it it's been probably
almost like a year since this like last
July was like that fart attack video is
really the last one and since then we've
been working with actors and stuff and
it's actually really fun just kind of
going back to it where it's like we
don't need actors we don't need anything
it's just like a camera small crew just
us just make a funny video in the woods
and honestly it's it's really just easy
to just come up with funny stuff on set
mess around improv just have a good time
filming when it's like just a small
group of friends like that and just
trying to make people laugh and
entertains people so neither of us had
aspirations to actually be actors it's
good to have a face on the channel it's
good to let people know who's behind the
camera sometimes who's behind the camera
right now no no let's look oh my god
it's already good funny it's John John
glamorous like joke it's cool to have
few enough people where we have comedic
input and it's it's kind of makes it
easy to figure out what's gonna be added
in because like you know somebody will
give an idea and then everybody will
laugh and it psycho they won't like us
we should throw that in there
yeah I feel like most of the shoots I've
been on with you guys have always been
just like down to the wire but just
adding an extra day if you can afford it
or if you have the time for it I feel is
worth it
you